Now that you've seen alpha and jitter in action I'd like
you to use your new knowledge of them to explore the relationship
between friends initiated and age. Build your plot up in layers
and be sure to use the g g plot syntax. I really
recommend playing around with this in our studio, and then once
you've got your finalized plot, copy and paste your code into the
browser and submit it. There's no right or wrong answer here and
there's a couple of different ways to make the plot. So just
be sure that once you have your final plot, you copy and paste all of your code
into the browser and submit. After you've created your
plot, share any of your findings in the discussions.